it's kind of a you porn logo the pornhub
logo the pornhub yeah
you i like you porn as you can tell yeah
but uh i
i love it i and you know i was thinking
about this when you said that earlier
and we started just talking i go
look at the [__] platforms and never
have an issue
porn yeah well they're actually hearing
anything
they're actually just recently having
lots of issues pouring up
they just recently got like a 600
million dollar class action lawsuit
against them and they had for what
i forget exactly what it was for i'd
have to read the article someone's not
getting [__] up
the right way yeah something like yeah
something like that
are you serious yeah man yeah they're
they're getting they're under the
[__]
they're getting the screws tightened up
right now and talk about free speech why
should they be because it's probably
religious right pushing this or whatever
it is
i don't know they uh they had to remove
like
a huge amount of their content from like
people
unverified people uploading their own
content and
and monetizing on their website so now
they're only allowed to have
certain verified porn actors on there
and it's really i don't like that
oh no no no it's [__] i don't see
that with you point and i think you
pornhub owns you they're all porn hubs
getting crushed right now but i think
don't they own you two
point two i thought i saw that they did
i think they're all connected
yeah i'm not sure i don't know i'm
honored enough you think i'd know but
there's a lot of
there's a weird thing there's a lot of
people that are that are really really
against
the porn industry i've had people on
here well that's people who don't want
[__] get hard-ons right you get wet
in a [__] or something
i i don't get it i really don't because
listen that's
talk about free speech porn stars
i have met like female porn actors i've
met have
the most character out of most people i
meet
i'm not sure why it is i met male ones
in the same way
i think it's because they're normal
people what i've noticed is that
to do porn you have to be desperate i
think
disagree i think that i knew i knew a
porn star
i think but i think her family through
college did everything oh totally
but most people that i've met or that
i've
heard about the way they got into porn
first
was they were in a situation that they
desperately needed to get out of
financially
and when you're that you got the money
when you're that young
say you're a young hot whatever 16 17 18
year old girl
no no don't please never go underneath
under 18 okay whatever
but it happens no those those to me
see i'm a very liberal person uh but
when it comes to
a child right i i i don't buy it well
whatever age that it happens and i don't
mean
ryan right you know let me give you a
quick one on the prison
we used to we you know child molesters
are no good in person no
obviously but i used to chomos
i used to pull the paperwork that means
i used to get
who what charge there was
ryan 20 whatever 21
[__] a 17 or 16. he had a pass
that wasn't even child abuse we called
it that wasn't even anything that was
free
right you at 30 whatever yeah
[__] a 15 year old that's not good
right so i know you look young right but
your brain should be at least old
now i know it's crazy you have to put a
number somewhere
if it's 18 19 20 you want to do it you
can [__] do it in the [__] one
it's just just like the military you can
shoot well that's a that's a whole other
weird thing too because then
now you're you're letting the [__]
legal system decide
and age when biologically
but biologically people are different no
no i 100 agree with that because even
girl you should
full mature [__] adult girls with a
giant [__]
rack at 15 at 15 years old absolutely
okay
strip the government and laws away from
from our monkey selves and
in nature that things [__] absolutely
absolutely but since we do have laws
right
listen you have a car why can't you
drive a car at 16 or 15
right when you're a mature let's even go
one better
which drives me nuts how can you tell a
kid to go to the military at 18 and kill
somebody and you can't drink
right it's insane it's insane
if you're 18 years old and you've got a
[__] rifle and you're in iraq and you
kill someone
you don't think their brains are [__]
up that's another whole topic
but why can't they come back and have a
drink now to get arrested because
they're [__] underage but they can
[__] take up rifles
defend the country i don't buy that one
and a lot of countries don't either
canada they can drink at 18 all that
kind of [__] whatever
but and when i grew up it was 18. see i
i don't know that
feeling of that right when i was 18 i
was in the service at 17.
at [__] 18 years old said i'm in the
bars man i was [__] oh 18 years old i
was
i was the [__] biggest idiot on the
planet when i was exactly
stealing well me too but you know that's
just the maturity though
since we have to put a number on it you
know
and i i you 100 and i do agree with you
you go back to some of the ancient times
once the girl had her period
she became a woman right and and they
had kids and this
and everything else i don't know what
but that's just the laws that came up
you know and we have to have something
yeah there has to be a base
level so where do you put it at right my
my thought my original thought i was
getting to with the porn thing is that
the pattern i see is that especially
with girls when they're young
18 say 18 years old they're in an
abusive situation they're living they're
dependent on whatever it may be
an abusive uncle right that's the only
place they have to stay
but they gotta get they gotta get out of
there when you're that young
what's the easiest way for you to make
the most amount of money
prostitution or porn drugs or right
but that's prostitution and porn are
probably the two
most common things probably and when you
get into there you can probably make the
most amount of money doing that then
when you start the climbing election
making more and more money
i'm gonna disagree because there's not
not many 18 year olds
who could do that on their own and what
i mean by that is
uh yeah when you're with a pimp and
you're
in your construction how do you find the
guys and stuff
although the internet has changed a lot
but are they smart enough because if
they're smart enough to set that
business up because it's a business
right and get someone to drive and not
get hurt and do everything else because
at all it is
then then they're probably smart enough
to do something else and it wouldn't
have been the situation
or maybe they would and obviously some
just look at it like you and i
might and you know listen i was always a
person that
sexy sex sex is sex it's not
the relationship itself right you know
uh
i think you know i often tell guys
listen
if if or a girl i'll tell her if you
caught your husband
getting a [__] would you leave her oh
he's [__] done i said well then leave
now
because if your husband can go to a
bachelor party and get a [__] [__]
and that's the end of your [__]
marriage
then you didn't have a deep relationship
anyway i mean the sex is the [__] sex
we're physical we you know
you watch pornhub what do you do you get
a [__] heart on right
right is that cheating i mean
so you got the physical blow oh but
there's that level always stick it
now i often say now differently
if your husband or your wife is in a
relationship
right then there's something deeper i
mean
she wants the the the protection the
love the
whatever the financial whatever it is
whatever you weren't giving her and
that's all that
but if your husband goes out and gets
laid he's in a [__] bachelor he's at
a [__] convention and he [__] got
drunk and he got [__]
is it the end of all some people are
gonna [__] call you right you and
maybe me and say yeah
yeah that is the [__] wrong you know
that's your own thing yeah to me it's
not
right you know i don't believe i believe
well you have to have that sort of deal
i think ahead of time yeah and i do yeah
but no i i you have to have the unders a
mutual understanding of that well that's
communication right it gets back to that
and all that kind of stuff i i'm a
believer in
listen we are very sexual people in life
and a lot of things to me have fun man
too many people
listen you know i'm looking at my age
you're young you guys are young and
which i love i really do
i'm at the age where i know i'm gonna
live 20 [__] more years
i know that sounds morbid it's not
morbid at all
i'll be [__] hating it i think you'll
go more than that